[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
boom [__] new now they're crying
losing their minds their tears are
delicious aren't they oh man maybe
they'll go in a cup of coffee maybe the
cup of coffee that you had while you're
watching Texas Paul's show
Texas Paul and the potheads are in the
house he says welcome on Wednesday we
did it we did it Texas Paul
oh thanks for joining us here on
Wednesday June 14th
the day after the second arraignment
after Donald Trump went to his Club in
Bedminster
who knows what's buried up there
what what do you want from me I I'm
can't not point out
that he buried his ex-wife at Bedminster
after he had her cremated and
1200 people had to carry the casket I
mean documents are heavy boxes of
documents are [__] heavy folks
that's why you gotta you know have
enough staff at your golf resort keep
this in mind when you're ever making
sure to commit felonies would classify
documents that you're not supposed to
have keeping them in a way that you're
not supposed to and then trying to hide
them from the people trying to get them
legally
and committing obstruction with intent
of criminality
keep this in mind when you do this folks
that you're gonna want you're gonna want
plenty of staff
at your
[__] roach infested Golf Course Hotel
slash
wedding venue
trashy wedding venue you're definitely
going to want to plenty of staff to move
around boxes
of documents that are going to get you
federally indicted that is a piece of
advice that you're gonna want to walk
away with here today
oh man so yesterday
as I typically do I go on Twitter and I
go in one of these Twitter spaces with
uh these moglodytes
yesterday
um have you ever heard of this guy DC
Drano you've seen this [__] Trump
retreuce him if you want to call it that
over on the true social all the time he
was really upset yesterday when I called
him delusional
he was really pissed off I mean he got
mad he got triggered in the space
these people get triggered very easy
you just have to I don't know start
dropping facts that's why I always warn
Gabe Sanchez here on the show listen
with your facts and stuff
it's gonna hurt their delegate
Sensibility
[Laughter]
oh man everyone knows you DC Drano is
they're saying yeah he's a
he is a turd and Kevin says wanker he is
a turd
oh DC Drano
um too bad we can't drain him
so
um I I go in there and and it was uh it
was delicious as a matter of fact
they're absolute [__] delusion and
their tears over what happened yesterday
in the arraignment is [__] delicious
now they're trying to find any stupid
[__] legal narrative that they can to
discredit the 49-page indictment that
the doj is brought against Donald Trump
with the vote of a grand jury
okay
they're trying everything they can and
by the way by the way I want to point
out I was correct yesterday when I said
Jack Smith would be sitting in that
courtroom
I knew he probably wouldn't be the one
speaking but he was sitting in that
courtroom and I can just imagine
him trying to make eye contact for that
[__] ass [__]
and Donald Trump wouldn't even look his
Direction because he's terrified
terrified he's a coward he is
Donald Trump
is
the picture perfect coward in this case
but Jack Smith
um yesterday they arraigned Donald Trump
now uh again the two-tier justice system
that Maga keeps bitching about it does
exist
the reason why they're mad is because
the second tier isn't protecting their
orange deity as much as they would like
it to yesterday it did protect him
though I don't know if you noticed this
yesterday guy didn't have to do a mug
shot he got special treatment going into
the courthouse
uh he received all sorts of security
not only that he had no conditions on
his travel
no conditions on his travel when he was
released of his own recognance
none the only the only restriction that
the judge placed on Donald Trump is a
restriction that should be placed on
every single criminal Federal defendant
which is that you cannot tamper with
Witnesses
which I'm sure that is a condition he's
absolutely going to break
but the the court yesterday afforded him
his second tier privilege
his rich white man tear privilege
yesterday when they released him of his
own recognance
and uh he didn't have any conditions
there's none he didn't have to hand over
his passport he didn't have to have
permission to travel wherever the [__]
he wants
which uh in an average uh in an average
federal
defendant's case they absolutely have
travel restriction they absolutely have
to hand over their passport they
absolutely are given restrictions but
not not him nope because it's a two-tier
justice system
when manga says that they're correct
again whenever whenever they're
propagandizing whenever a gaslighting
the country that's what they always do
that's that's the best way to do it is
to grab a little kernel of the truth and
then turn it on its head and say the
opposite of what is true right
and the opposite of what they're saying
is true is that yes there is a two-tier
justice system and it's designed to
protect Donald Trump that's why they're
mad that's why they're mad about oh
Hillary Clinton had classified emails on
a server
well my friend maybe just maybe you're
not thinking this through about how how
that is not illegal I mean in Donald
Trump's case the one thing they want to
talk about which is all [__] by the
way that Donald Trump can declassify
documents with his mind that's it's just
not how it works it's not
it's not the president can declassify
things but you can't just say well six
years ago I Declassified that with my
mind because if that was the case
if that was the case then Barack Obama
could say today right now right now
Barack Obama could come out and say you
know what come to think of it when I was
President of the United States I I
Declassified all those emails that
Hillary had with my mind
you follow me
do you do you understand how stupid that
sounds
that if Barack Obama went on an
interview right now right
somewhere and said you know what
I'm just gonna put an end to this
argument of the Hillary Clinton thing
and just let you know
that when I was President I I
Declassified all those emails
because I did it with my mind
and now I'm remembering this that I did
declassify those things so bam now
they're Declassified so you can't do
anything about it and that's why James
Comey couldn't do anything about it
because I Barack Obama is the president
United States Declassified all those
emails
it's the dumbest [__] thing I've ever
heard in my life
that's the can you imagine us the
pro-democracy Coalition trying to defend
that argument like what the [__] listen
like I said that's ridiculous okay
here we are all these years later and
Barack Obama can just decide that he
Declassified them all the way back then
and he didn't tell nobody he didn't tell
anybody he didn't need to tell nobody he
doesn't need to tell nobody okay he's
the president of the United States don't
you know this
hello
the president United States has has
absolute power over declassifying
documents no matter what
that's their logic
okay
but that's not what he committed crime
doing
classified or Declassified it doesn't
matter it's National Security
information
it doesn't matter if it's classified or
Declassified you [__] boneheads
he had possession of national security
information he was showing it to people
who didn't have clearance and then and
then
on top of that
he was obstructing
Nara and the doj to get the government's
documents back they're not it's not your
[__] man they keep saying the
presidential records Act and the reason
why they say that is because again
that's the kernel of Truth here right
yes the presidential records act does
dictate what is his personal records and
what is the records of the office of
President while he was there
it defines that in the law you [__]
idiots
but the presidential records act doesn't
give him the right to do whatever he
wants and takes all of it
now
intent matters and motive matters too
and to assume
to assume that we as Layman have read
this indictment and know the entire case
that the government's going to make
against the 37 [__] counts of charges
that they brought against Donald Trump
and the grand jury voted to indict
foreign
we do not get to see the evidence we do
not get to see the discovery as it is
called in the courts and between the
attorneys but it's the evidence
that the government has collected
against Donald Trump in the attempt to
prove that the charges that the grand
jury voted to indict him on that he is
guilty of okay got it
now you can whine and you can cry and
you can [__] and you can moan
about what happened yesterday but
nothing that happened yesterday is
anyone but Donald Trump private citizens
fault
he was not the president when when they
the the the events that they charged him
for and then arraigned him on yesterday
he was not the president when that when
those charges
happen on for the crimes that he
allegedly committed
he was not the president
he was not no matter what Q Anon tells
you
you can't
believe
on one hand
that what Hillary Clinton did should
have put her into prison with the
evidence that you had and then read the
evidence that is laid before you in this
indictment and not want the same for
Donald Trump unless
you are in a cult
it is a cult folks
100 percent and they're the cult
is the tail that is wagging the dog and
the dog's not even Donald Trump at this
point it's a Republican Party
yesterday you watched as DeSantis
supporters became very disgruntled
for D santis where is Ron where's
[__] Ron at where's that [__]
he's is he hiding why isn't he out in
front of a microphone answering
questions about the front runner the
criminal front runner and in his party
that he's trying to seek denomination
and why won't he attack him on those
crimes where is Ronnie where's he at
that's right he's a coward he's weak I
told you this
I've been telling you this over and over
and over and over again and I'm going to
say it a million times more Donald Trump
is going to be their [__] nominee and
not a goddamn person is going to stand
in their way and yesterday you watched
as to Santa supporters became very very
very [__] destroyed
because of the support
that was out and about
for Donald Trump including from the
other candidates
vivec being one of them
standing in front of the courthouse
calling for all the other candidates for
president including RFK and Marianne
Williamson [__] out of here they're not
candidates for president okay
get it through your thick [__] skulls
calling on all the other candidates to
to to promise to Pardon Trump if they
become president get the [__] out of
here with this nonsense
we already made that mistake in this
country once Gerald Ford should have
never pardoned Nixon and my belief is my
belief is going back to history if
Gerald Ford would not have pardoned
Nixon we would not be having some of the
problems we're having right now with
Grandpa Poopypants
this would be much more defined it would
be it would have it would have been much
easier than
to bring a case against Gerald Ford for
him to take a plea deal just like
General Petraeus did you remember
General Petraeus he's another one that
took took advantage of the two-tier
justice system did you know that
he took advantage of the two-tier
justice system as well that's right
you remember David Petraeus he was
having someone write his book they were
schlubbing he uh he left the classified
information and National Security
information in her possession when he
shouldn't have
he was charged with a felony
he kept his mouth shut kept his head
down and eventually negotiated it down
to a misdemeanor with the prosecutors
a criminal misdemeanor
you remember that and that was one
document one well one set of documents
that he left with his author
slash mistress
but Petraeus
was able to take advantage of the
two-tier justice system that they're
just absolutely upset that yesterday
came down on Donald Trump finally Jesus
Christ after how many [__] decades
is this son of a [__] finally gonna pay
some accountability hmm
but all they can yell and scream about
this morning
is is
Hillary Clinton an otter Biden and 17
tapes that don't exist
they're losing the plot line by the way
which is good I mean this is good that
they're losing the plotline but I I I
sense that there's a new political
strategy coming out of the far right
there's a new political strategy that is
coming from uh Team Trump if you want to
call it that
I sense a new political strategy and
they've started to deploy it now we'll
see over the coming weeks if that if my
theory proves correct
but if my theory proves correct
in this political strategy that they
have this narrative and messaging
strategy that they have
we're gonna have to [__] pay
attention
and we're gonna have to do the work
because they're deploying this strategy
across all channels
and they're really trying it out they're
really trying out the messaging on this
new strategy
so we have to stay vigilant we have to
keep our eyes open and our ears to the
ground and know how to protect our
democracy and how we do that
as we engage in our democracy
yeah we're not it's not going to do it
for us right
and as I told you yesterday and I know
it's hard to hear and I know people
don't want to hear it that Donald Trump
is not going to see a trial until after
the election
okay
period
Donald Trump will not see a trial
until after the election
the the sooner you come to that
realization the easier this is going to
be to engage because we are the jury now
we are the next jury that he will have
to contend with We the People the vote
the ballot
is the jury
that he will have to contend with first
and I know you want to have hope that he
will see a trial
but don't get your hopes up
do not get your hopes up
because if you're getting your hopes up
now you're going to be disappointed and
boy is it really going to breed
suppression
that's right self-suppression is a
problem in voting blocks
and we cannot we cannot self-suppress
our vote this is way too important
to the future of our constitutional
Democratic Republic
it's literally the only thing that
matters
is that they the fascist the maglonites
the America First Nazi party does not
retain power
in any shape or any form yes we have to
take the presidency yes we have to move
the needle and the Senate and yes we
have to take back the house but down the
ballot there is a chance that we can
undo some of these Nazi super majorities
in these red States you don't believe me
you may laugh me off but it is possible
but we have to know their strategy
to have a counter-offensive because we
have to use our strategic outrage to
engage in our democracy
so that we the jury the people the vote
decide
what we will be going forward
so just keep this all in mind again I'm
I'm hip to their new strategy I've
already found it
and we will see if the deployment of it
is successful
if it is you damn well better bet I'm
gonna be pointing it out here
you damn well better bet we're going to
make sure
that we appoint our strategic outrage
to absolutely destroy and dismantle
their their strategy
and that's what we do here at the Tony
Michaels podcast
they get really mad when I go on these
Twitter spaces oh there's some [__]
idiot in there yesterday talking about
all kinds of legal [__] legal This legal
that oh this case that case I'm like
look you dumb bastards no one in America
is gonna pay attention to any of that
none of it and all your emotions and all
your Ridiculousness about the legality
of the of the indictment and what's
going to happen in your prediction in
the legal realm guess how many Americans
give a [__] about that not that [__]
many not that many
I mean yeah as a percentage it's really
small and it may be a lot of people that
are paying attention
but percentage-wise it's just not that
much people don't give a [__] it's
horrible I wish it was different I wish
we right now in this moment in history
could get everyone to give a [__] but we
can't it's gonna take time folks it's
gonna take time
that's what you have to understand about
the politics of this and Republicans
have always played the long game and
strategy and narrative and since Donald
Trump became their leader it is the
exact opposite there is no long-term
strategy it is just walk into the china
shop and try to destroy everything in
sight it's a chaos machine
but we can do this
this is possible matter of fact if we do
it together it'll be very [__] easy
very [__] easy
because again the American people don't
give two shits
about all the legal strategy and the
motions and what's in this indictment
and what predicated case you're going to
use to make this argument
was it this was it that in the legality
of it oh this legal beagle thing shut
the [__] up America doesn't give a [__]
about that
there's only two things that America
heard about yesterday only two words
Trump arrested okay most Americans when
he got arrested for what Espionage Act
what Espionage he's a spy that's what
they heard yesterday okay
most Americans that's what the [__] they
heard and if you're out there going oh
well that should just do it that's not
gonna do it it's not gonna end it
I mean yeah are they sick and tired of
his ass sure absolutely the average
American is sick and tired of having to
talk about Trump
and the only reason why we're talking
about it is because Republicans in the
Senate didn't [__] throw him away in
the garbage after he tried to overthrow
our [__] vote and try to take over
our democracy as dictator and King and
commit a Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
that's the only reason why we're still
talking about him they would have 14th
him then
would be done and over with
yes maybe he still would have took the
documents yes he may have committed
crimes but no one would give a [__]
the way they do now is this country is
like yeah he's a criminal log him up who
gives a [__]
you think the majority of this country
gives a good goddamn if Donald Trump
goes to prison or not
over crimes he committed they absolutely
do not care if he goes to prison they
don't give a [__]
they don't care just like they would go
to prison if they committed crimes they
want him to and this whole narrative
that oh if they can do it to him they
can do it to you most Americans are like
yeah if they can do it to me they sure
as hell better be able to do it to him
but that's not what the delusional
Association vote is working off of
their narrative has been clear
for the last Almost year over this
document's case
specifically this documents case but
more than anything the cult leader
Donald Trump himself
and I told them yesterday this is where
DC Drano in that Twitter space got very
upset at me
I told them
that their delusion
Trump supporters delusion and the people
who know its delusion but are still
[__] diluting their own [__]
people to believe this garbage lying to
them propagating them
their delusion
is going to be the demise of Donald
Trump
because with Donald Trump the one thing
that he gets right folks in politics the
one thing that he's done masterfully in
politics
is he lets the Tail Wag the Dog
he encourages it actually he figures out
what will Wag the Dog and he uses it
over and over and over again
that's what he does it's what he does
best
he doesn't have any actual thoughts of
his own
But Here In This Moment
here in this moment we must engage in
our democracy and shut down their
delusion
so it does not spread
because again his delusion their
delusion is going to be his demise
because he actually believes that
[__] now I think he really does
believe that he is Untouchable if you go
back to Jim Jones right remember Jim
Jones
the Kool-Aid
and Guiana
at some point Jim Jones believed his own
[__]
because he convinced his supporters of
that [__] and they convinced him
that what he was saying was true
and when they found out he was a [__]
lunatic and there was no way out of that
camp in Guyana
there was no way out it was too late
it was way too late and it was the
ultimate demise of Jim Jones
unfortunately
he poisoned the Kool-Aid
well
we haven't reached the Kool-Aid moment
yet in the Maga cult we haven't
I know it feels like at some points we
have but we have not
we're not there at the Kool-Aid moment
yet
but stay tuned because I think I think
we're getting close to a Kool-Aid moment
if you if you want to know the truth so
you're not going to want to miss a
single episode of the Tony Michaels
podcast so subscribe down below it is
free to subscribe here on YouTube
if you want to give a super chat on
YouTube I know I I'm not monetized on
YouTube they [__] hate my guts what
am I supposed to do even if I open up a
new channel or some [__] they wouldn't
monetize me because of the [__] I say
and how I say it I'm surprised I'm still
on YouTube sometimes I'm not
uh but I'm gonna keep yelling and
screaming because of you folks because
no matter where we go you're gonna go
and follow you're gonna watch this is
this this show is the I believe is going
to be
this The Shining City on the hill of
left-wing liberal propaganda
pro-democracy propaganda
as the right would call it yeah some
people have referred to me as the rush
limb ball of the left some have said
that
and I think maybe maybe that's true to
some degree I don't know if that's true
or not but the point is is that you're
the audience and you're the greatest
audience in the world
and when you the audience engages in
this show that is what matters that is
what will advance our democracy that is
what will grow the pro-democracy
Coalition that is what will solidify the
narrative all around the country to win
not not just not just for Democrats but
for rights for freedom and for Liberty
for equity and equality for everyone
here not just American citizens not just
the white Christian nationalist everyone
that is inside of our borders
we can protect their Liberty by by
making it more equal and more Equitable
for every single person no matter who
they are where they come from or what
their experience is even the toothless
mangas we can do this we can show them
that hey look I understand that you know
you got these bigoted [__] views but
look
and inclusiveness Liberty and rights and
freedom for all
is actually the way that you're going to
get the things that you want the things
that you desire to have a better life
here in this country where we should be
free we should have rights and we should
have our Liberty I also go to Twitter
because you're not going to want to miss
over there on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod and we've been tweeting a lot more
from that account
and it's going to be bone end of the
week tomorrow you're going to get the
vote tomorrow for bone Hen of the week I
have some bad news Gabe Sanchez isn't
going to be joining us today he'll be
back tomorrow he's got a special
surprise for you tomorrow too by the way
so you got me for two full hours today
here on the Tony Michaels podcast and
you can watch me
on YouTube or on Facebook
for that entire two hours just go to
Tony Michaels if you still have a
Facebook account follow us there you can
also watch us on the up wire on YouTube
just go to the upwire.com click the link
there or you can search the up wire on
YouTube and I want to thank everyone
over on Twitch great chat over on Twitch
always as always it's growing growing
growing over there on Twitch you go to
twitch.tv slash D Tony Michaels you can
follow us for free we've had so many
people re-subscribe and subscribe uh
this morning Paulie 77 is resubscribed
and that's four months in a row
um Leah Kelly has subscribed with their
Prime account this morning uh Molly
re-subscribe for two months so thank you
very much for everyone
who has subscribed and re-subscribed
using your Prime account on Twitch what
happens is if you link your Prime
account to your Twitch account you get
one free subscription on Twitch you can
give it to us the Tony Michaels podcast
and that gives us a couple bucks each
month and it doesn't cost you a single
extra nickel if you're a prime
subscriber so thank you for all the
prime subscribers going over and using
your one free subscription by linking
your Prime account to your Twitch
account and giving us a couple bucks of
Amazon's money every single month and
you got to renew it every month you got
to re-subscribe and the free money isn't
easy money but it doesn't take that long
just go to the Tony michaels.com look at
the directions there it's like the
fourth link down our great moderator the
mighty librarian came up with the
directions there so just go to the Tony
michaels.com click on the link that says
link your Amazon and Prime account
to your Twitch account it's right there
on the tonymichaels.com and I want to
thank all the mods while I while I'm on
it Robin over on on Twitch all the mods
here
here on YouTube
we have to thank them we have to thank
them
um so much and uh also so we have MJ
Cynthia Allison Amanda Deidra Jim over
on the up wire everyone go give Jim some
love on the up wire he's been uh
in the seat they're moderating not so
much when we were suspended over on the
up wire but you get what I mean so go to
the Tony michaels.com show us support
there for all the links there at
thetonymichaels.com one more plug while
I'm at it you might as well when you get
to tonymichaels.com you might as well
click on the [__] a merch go to store
that beat Tony michaels.com to get your
[__] em Pride merch and Miss loveseek
had the idea in the chat to do a pride
themed [__] em logo
and because she said it in the chat of
course you guys commented and left a lot
of with a lot of
great reviews and that's what you wanted
so Gabe Sanchez came up with that design
and delivered for you on store not the
Tony michaels.com everyone stick around
we're gonna be right back right after
this
[Music]
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds the
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
oh boy now we got a lot of Clips to go
through today there's plenty of manga
tears out there to go around
if you think they are delicious if you
think they are delicious what doesn't
make
something more delicious than marketeers
really honestly is there anything
I mean you can put marketeers on a dog
turd and it would make it taste better
don't you think I think so
I mean I wouldn't just be going around
eating dog turds but if you're putting
marketeers on them
my I might I might give it a little bit
of consideration I'm just saying
and they're all over the map right like
they're all over the map with their
arguments they can't figure out exactly
which argument they want to make but
again I'm on I'm on to their uh strategy
for narrative here and again I don't
want to give away the game until I know
for sure that there is a a very
strategic move to change the narrative
in this country
and to release a new word
and a new phrase out into the open
um but I'm on to it I'm on to it I'm on
to it I'm always watching very closely
of what their narrative is uh you know
me now
this is this is the best clip from
yesterday and this basically this
basically sums up
the entire Maga movement their entire
[__] whiny [__] little
and um
fit that they threw yesterday over this
guy committing crimes and getting caught
and the evidence stacking up against him
and then him being indicted now look I
used to call him the Cheeto dust mobster
you remember that I used to call him the
Cheeto dust mobster I changed it
to the Cheeto dust cue in honor and the
reason why I changed it
is because
when
when he's really started to post on
Truth social it became clear to me that
this guy was really not a good mobster
right I mean he's a wannabe monster they
want to be uh part of the the crime
family that's why that's what the
projection is when they say the Biden
crime family right that's their
projection
when they're trying to project their
misdeeds onto someone else right now
I switched it to Tudor dust q and honor
because he's not a very good mobster and
if you have read this indictment
at all like just past the second or
third page if you just you don't have to
really go past the third page much
do you understand that over a year ago
when I switched his nickname from the
Cheeto dust mobster to the Cheeto dust q
and honor that I was correct then
that is when I that is when
I noticed that yes I need to change the
name
some people are saying Trump trump is
speaking victimes yes he's very fluent
in victimies I lost that comment
so
I changed his name
from mobster to q anoner and the reason
why is because this guy is not a good
mobster at all he's not
he's not Mobsters don't do what he does
they just don't they may try to commit
crime like he does but they don't react
to it like he does
um here is here's Donald Trump now this
is four seconds
of what will become
known as the whiniest bitchiest
statement that a former president and a
presidential candidate has ever made
ever in the history of ever
yeah they're they're gonna teach this
in history lessons to your grandchildren
one of these days folks
oh my God
oh they certainly are
going to teach this and that is the
trouble with all this because I mean you
know whatever we're gonna we're gonna
band together as a pro-democracy
coalition we're gonna slam dunk this
idiot into the trash again next year I'm
very confident in that I just want it to
be as big of a defeat for him and his
allies and the Republican party that is
possible right I want the biggest defeat
that's why I want us to work hard dig in
keep keep our eyes open our ears to the
ground and get in the fight
and win for our democracy not just win
some elections I'm talking about win for
our democracy listen to this this is a
four second clip
you can't get more victims than this I
did everything right and they indicted
me
I'm serious that's real this is an AI
this is not AI here well let me play
back I just to prove that it's real I
did everything right and they indicted
me have you ever have you ever like
encountered a little kid like a little
kid in a grocery store that wants a
certain [__] cereal but his mom's
like no you don't get four different
cereals you only get one
and he throws a fit
[__] shaking the cart laying on the
ground kicking his [__] feet acting
acting like a [__] baby you ever seen
this before now different parents react
different ways right when this happens
you see some parents pick that kid up
and whisper in his ear
and the kid looks very frightened after
the parent Whispers in their ear right
that's what should have happened with
Donald Trump years ago
the Republican Party should have picked
him up and whispered in his ear do you
remember do you remember the moment uh
when they were voting for Kevin McCarthy
do you remember this when Matt gatz and
Lauren bobert were sitting next to each
other right
and they weren't going to vote for Kevin
McCarthy they weren't going to let him
be speaker whatever the [__] they
thought they were gonna do
and that the guy that the the
representative from from Tennessee
bird [__] bird [__] remember the guy he
stood on the step side we can't do
anything about gun violence just
something we can't do anything bad just
let him die who gives a [__] we can't do
anything about it anyways remember him
he leaned into Matt Gatson he whispered
something to him you remember that he
leaned in and he whispered something to
Matt gants in his ear
and Matt gatz decided that okay yeah I
should uh we should go ahead and make
Kevin McCarthy
the speaker of the house this is what
should have happened to Donald Trump a
long time ago now there's more reactions
to the kid in the grocery store kicking
his feet slamming on the cart yelling
and screaming one of the reactions is
the parents standing the kid up and
smacking him on the ass right
maybe a couple swans that could be a
reaction a lot of you don't like that
reaction that could be a reaction
sometimes that gets a different
alternate reaction from the child maybe
more of an outburst right
okay you follow
now
at some point and I'm not you know
promoting spanking here but at some
point the Republican Party first
impeachment should have
should have spanked the [__] out of
Donald Trump
okay
that's the next reaction another
reaction is this
when the kid just won't stop won't quit
the parent leaves the cart right where
it is right in the [__] aisle I mean
right there doesn't hesitate
she grabs her purse she grabs the child
by the ways picks him up takes him
outside to the car because what she's
about to do to him she does not want
other people to see
you've seen this before too Hey listen I
was a kid once I got taken out to the
car I'm not gonna lie it happened to me
maybe that's what's wrong with me but
that is also another reaction that a
parent could have right
that's another reaction wrong right and
different that's what should have
happened after the Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup in the second impeachment
they should have taken him out back a
behind the wood shed and spanked his ass
that's what they should have done
they didn't do that
this entire time not only not only
have they been silent but they've
encouraged him
they cheer and they laugh look he's
throwing a fit hey everyone hey everyone
hey everyone from the grocery store come
and see my child throw a fit
it's so great come and see him throw a
fit over over wanting four cereals
instead of three he's a spoiled little
[__] and he's whiny and we love him I
love him you want to love him come love
him laugh at him clap for him act like
he's a circus clown that's what they
have done this entire time in this
situation where the little boy loses his
mind in the grocery store we're not
getting the fourth sugar sugary cereal
that he wants
and that's what this is that's what this
is listen to them cheer him
I did everything right and they indicted
me
I do yeah we I did everything right and
they invaded me
foreign
are going to say this is just a four
second clip out of minutes minutes that
he was whining and bitching crying
possibly [__] exposing himself to
more criminal charges
we learned yesterday that the judge and
the E Gene Carroll case is absolutely
going to let her pile on to the
defamation case oh [__]
I can't wait until he he he's asked a
question about the Eugene Carroll case
so she can pile more on him
but this is this is the historical
moment
yesterday
that manga is waiting for
this is their moment of him being their
great leader watch again I did
everything right and they indicted me
that is their moment of their great hero
yesterday that's it in four seconds you
can sum it up
now I'm gonna show you more especially
more marketeers
um it looks like um
it looks like Texas Paul may join us at
the top of the hour so Texas Paul if
you're still there uh hang on I'll do a
break at the top of the hour I'll send
you a uh
I'll send you a link to get into the uh
the studio here and that way you can if
you want you can join me for the latter
half of the Tony Michaels podcast now I
want to go I want to go to another clip
here of this morning
um where Tom Cotton is on Hugh Hewitt's
show this is really important uh Tom
Cotton trying to get his narrative out
there trying to trying to try out the
narrative and see how it works here's
Tom Cotton On Hugh Hewitt's radio show
this morning what Hillary Clinton did
was much worse than what Donald Trump is
alleged to Australia Donald Trump is
alleged to have taken documents
um of historical value and shown them to
people uh
at Mar-A-Lago didn't have security
clearances Hillary Clinton had set up an
unsecure server in her house conducting
diplomacy in real time on it on the
nation's most sensitive matters
um that the former deputy director of
CIA said on your show eight years ago
almost certainly was compromised in real
time by the Chinese or the Russians or
the Iranians or other adversaries of the
United States
and there you have the stupid argument
of what about ISM what about Hillary
again when when they start saying this
stupid [__] just say well I heard Obama
Declassified all her emails with his
mind just say that say it who gives a
[__] just say it because that is their
argument about Trump and again I know
it's like but Tony that's not real yeah
well they're not living in [__]
reality okay they're not living in
reality nor are they going to live in
reality it's not going to happen
it's not going to happen
you think they're gonna change their
minds about this their best argument Tom
Cotton who is a sitting United States
Senator best argument to defend Trump
this morning is that Hillary had a
server in her house where which housed
emails with classified markings two or
three of them
folks
the [__] was toting documents
all around the country to Mar-A-Lago to
Bedminster he had [__] Maps he had
secret National Security plans on how we
are going to attack Iran and he was
showing him around waving around in the
air
come on come on the Hillary case is not
the same and even if you want to make it
the same fine
okay fine whatever Obama and this is why
I'm saying fine whatever if you want to
make the same stupid arguments that
Trump is making about his case fine
Obama Declassified all those emails that
Hillary had on her server when he was
present with his mind he did it that's
what I heard a lot of people are saying
you're like well that's that's dirty is
is it is it dirty to use their own
stupid argument against them because you
know what they're gonna say to you
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
in my life because it is it's a really
stupid argument it's dumb it's dumb as
dog [__]
but then you're gonna point out you're
gonna point out that that's the argument
that you're making you [__] idiot
you think my argument's dumb well look
in the [__] mirror I want to show you
I'm speaking of looking in the mirror
a tweet I found this is hilarious this
is [__] real too I found this uh and
I did screenshots of it so that it
wouldn't be deleted uh this is Chris
losh I don't know if you guys know who
Dana losh is and Chris losh they're
they're right Wingers right they get
radio shows or whatever the [__] they're
big 2A proponents
Chris Lo's here this is his tweet
and this is after yesterday this is his
his reaction to Donald Trump
and the indictment and the arraignment
and his statement after
I don't know this is after the
indictment excuse me this wasn't up
until the statement but he's predicting
what Donald Trump's going to say here
because Donald Trump
is predictably unpredictable right and
Chris says in a tweet he says I'm tired
of quote release the Kraken
quote trust the plan quote there is a
storm coming talk meaning Q Anon Q Anon
and he says it never material nothing's
ever materialized and like Q anon's fake
Q anon's not real q anon's a bunch of
horseshit yeah no [__] Chris thanks
welcome to the [__] party dude
but he goes on to say now this is
hilarious this is hilarious watch the
cognitive dissonance here
not just in this this tweet but in the
next one I'm going to show you
he says also sic of the quote I will
beat the Deep State and drain the swamp
talk followed by quote well the swamp
cheated and beat me
follow closely with quote but next time
and he says Ugg so Chris is really tired
of the Republican lie that oh there's a
deep State and there's a swamp and we're
going to drain it which again there is
no [__] deep State there is no I mean
if there is a swamp it's the right wing
right there's no deep state but if there
is a swamp it's definitely the right
wing
and then the excuse that they keep
giving that they keep giving the right
Wingers these Cuban honors well the
swamp cheated and beat me
but I thought you're going to drain them
that you're gonna beat them but they
beat you before you can beat them is
that what you're saying and then they're
sick of hearing but the next time just
uh but the next time uh but the next
time ugh Chris says egg
now watch this next statement this is
beautiful folks look at the cognitive
dissonance here this is in the same
thread old Spitfire here tells Chris
Chris no one can drain the swamp not
Trump not DeSantis the corruption is too
deep the sooner you realize this the
better is what Spitfire says she goes on
to say it's a wasted talking point to
help either candidate
here's what Chris says holy [__] now
remember what he said in this one
remember what he said in his tweet this
is in the tweets thread folks Chris says
I'm not [__] you let me let me zoom
in on it here so you get a good look at
it
look at the cognitive dissonance here he
says I think you're wrong Spitfire
you're wrong
does Santa's can't drain it
has done it at the state level and has a
real plan with a great team to execute
to Bland when he wins it's the same
[__] [__] you just said you're tired
of Chris and you're doing it these
people don't have a clue
they don't have a clue
they're out to lunch
this
is not a dumb person Chris low she's I
mean he's a right winger and he's a
[__] and he's definitely an America
First Republican Nazi okay
but he's not dumb
but he definitely is delusional
he definitely is a member of the cult
even though he's he's on desantis's side
here
his cognitive dissonance is palpable
right and it's real in real time on
Twitter It's [__] amazing
and and a lot of people are you know
well how is Trump going to win
this is how he's going to win cognitive
dissidents that's how it works
whew holy moly oh let's go to a quick
break when we come back
I think Texas Paul is going to join us
as Texas Paul Wednesday apparently
or tripod ball Wednesday
oh he's not gonna like that one and
Mystics is probably gonna like that
either all right we'll be right back
right after this tripod Paul and it's
Wednesday we got all kinds of crazy
stuff going on Stick Around we'll be
right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
wait was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam gems skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show it
looks like we're gonna have breaking
news as possible that the Attorney
General mayor Garland is going to make
remarks at the top of the hour
um but on the Justice Department's
website it's not saying the statements
are going to be about Donald Trump it's
going to be about violent crime
um he's holding he's convening a meeting
with the U.S attorneys on violent crime
uh it appears that this was a
pre-planned meeting before the Donald
Trump indictment probably
um and it there's no no one is reporting
they are reporting that it exists and
this is going to be the first appearance
that Garland's going to have uh in front
of a camera after the Donald Trump
arraignment and actually I believe even
after the indictment and arraignment but
I don't believe that he probably will
make statements on the matter we will
stay tuned here and see if he's going to
make statements on the matter if he does
we'll bring you those statements um but
it doesn't it doesn't appear that that
is their plan I want to bring in Texas
Paul to taxes are tripod ball which is
it now Dex is Paul thanks thanks for
coming on and welcome to Wednesday my
friend
um Gabe Sanchez couldn't join us today
so I guess you're joining as the guest
co-host
um yet you're Mike muted there by the
way just just to point that out
um but um we're uh we're we're gonna be
in good shape today so what did you make
of uh Grandpa's uh little um uh hissy
fit last night at bitminster
I did everything right and they indicted
me I mean that's the only clip you need
but that's the only clip you need from
that whole thing that's like that's it
that's all you need here let me let me
see if I can play it I mean literally
like I'm like are you kidding me this is
the best you got holy [__] man and and
this is gonna be the clip that goes down
forever and ever and ever with this guy
whining to his Maga called here it is
again this is it don't don't look away
it doesn't take long either to see the
victimes that he's speaking here
that's not that's that's the wrong one
damn it this is the right one here we go
here we go here's the one
I did everything right and they indicted
me I did anything great they indicted me
it even sounds like a little kid losing
his mind in the grocery store doesn't it
it doesn't I love that I can't I can't
watch that clip without laughing I mean
I try to keep a straight face I can't do
it man that is freaking hilarious I did
everything right and they indicted me
hahaha
what a little [__] what a little [__]
pissed me off though that clip you
played to Tom Cotton you know the FBI
did a little investigation about that
server and they came back and said that
server was never compromised that she
had badass Security on that server and
and and for him to sit there and you
know what it shut up it's kind of funny
it's kind of funny because
that you bring that up because the
security on the server matters because
no one could access the server right but
when we go when we go and we question
these Trump supporters on the documents
that Mar-A-Lago they're like oh well not
just everyone can walk around Mar-A-Lago
but they can but they can and there's
been instances where spies have
infiltrated Mar-A-Lago because it's a
[__] public Resort the Clinton
residence was not a public Resort
it wasn't and then they go back to the
whole oh well Mar-A-Lago was protected
by secret service so those documents
were safe which is not by the way which
is not a secret Services Mission that's
not their mission to protect documents
at Mar-A-Lago nor are they going to make
that their mission but if that's the
argument that that's the stupid [__]
argument that you want to make the
server at the Clinton home was protected
by Secret Service then you [__]
buffoons
if that's the argument that they're
trying to make and that's why I said
yesterday in space and why I told the
audience today look when someone makes
that argument just say look it doesn't
matter because Barack Obama didn't you
hear Barack Obama Declassified all the
emails on Hillary's server with his mind
while he was President he remembered it
just the other day he woke up and you
know what I remember I Declassified all
those emails with my mind again that
sounds really stupid it's not true but
the whole point is to try to point out
their stupid [__] arguments here
because the indictment that happened and
the arraignment that happened yesterday
has nothing to do with these documents
rather he classify them or Declassified
them has nothing to do with it and that
has nothing to do with it all the
indictment all the charges came with his
conduct after he became president all of
it was after he became president not
while he was president and they failed
to [__] see that in the indictment
but it's not surprising is it
no no I mean you get those those two
arguments that you're just batting down
right there the first one with the
Secret Service do you ever watch Tick
Tock Tony you ever watch Tick Tock yeah
there's a video short thing that people
add in into their tick tocks it's a
little kid little guy sitting in the
back seat where he says uh [__] uh
[__] all right you've seen that one
yeah I've seen that one every time
someone says something about well though
you know the Secret Service was there to
practice that's exactly what flashes
into my mind uh [__]
it's a secret service you could have
those boxes say classified material
property of the United States America
Department of Defense whatever and
Donald Trump could stand there and hand
those boxes to people and they could
walk out the front freaking door and the
Secret Service would do nothing but take
their phone out
take a little picture click
text their boss and say hey I saw this
[__] this looks a little hinky right and
that would be it that would be it their
boss would say yeah that doesn't look
right hey uh maybe we should refer to
the other guy right yeah you know that
that would be it that would be there is
no secret service protection of
documents and they don't even protect
all of Mar-A-Lago right they don't well
because because their mission is to
protect Donald Trump at Mar-A-Lago
that's their mission that's their
mission and and and and they're going to
stick to that mission just the same way
that the Secret Service was protecting
the ex-president Bill Clinton and or the
former president whatever you want to
call it the former President Bill
Clinton at his home where the server was
so if you're gonna make the argument for
Trump you have to make it for Clinton
and and they keep ticking down this road
and I know what they're trying to do
Texas Paul I know what they're trying to
do they're they're trying to get
um liberals and folks in the media in
this trap of trying to rehash the
Clinton thing right that's that's their
trap here that's the Trap that they're
trying to set the problem is is it's not
gonna work and it is is obvious that
Jack Smith and his team beautifully
predicted this they knew this what was
going to happen that's why they told the
story that they told in the indictment
with the evidence that they put in the
indictment especially the material
evidence in the indictment is they
wanted to tell that story I want to show
you another clip of some more marketeers
I know you'll like these marketeers
they're they're uh they're laced with
cocaine
um so hang on tight here this is Donald
Trump throw a prop to you though Tony
yeah go ahead because what you just said
there I can't let it go man what you
just said there this is gonna sound
arrogant arrogant as crap but it's the
truth and
tell me I'm wrong they would have gotten
away with that [__] 10 years ago when we
were not here when you were not here
when I was not here when Midas Touch
Network wasn't here and you had people
now that we have people outside the
corporate media space that are calling
them on their [__]
all they would have gotten was that
corporate media [__] that would have
repeated those talking points and they'd
have got away with that [__] right we
are the reason and I don't give a damn
if anybody wants to say oh yeah Paul
yeah no [__] I talked to
a pardon the expression Tony a [__] ton
of people and I've you know I knocked
this [__] down all day long you talk to
a [__] ton of people you knock this [__]
down all day long this is why they're
not getting away with this crap and
we're not going to let them I mean we're
just not gonna let them well there's no
there's no network uh mainstream Network
out there that is going to tell Their
audience hey when they say this [__]
tell them that Barack Obama
Declassified all the emails with his
mind there's not they're not gonna No
One's Gonna tell you to do that and and
the mainstream media is derelict in
their Duty when they're not showing the
false equivalency of these arguments
like stop stop placating to their
arguments show the audience and show the
country why their arguments [__] suck
show them why they suck don't just tell
them that they suck
show them why they suck speaking of
sucky arguments here's um again these
marketeers are delicious but they are
laced and cocaine so hang on to help
someone that's polling at 0.2 percent
right now is a dollar that we don't have
to go up against the regime machine uh
it's a dollar that we don't have to fund
the ballot harvesting operations that
we're going to need to have to win uh
and that's why some of these people are
going to stay on the race again their
Consultants their donors they don't want
Donald Trump to win and these are the
Republicans that we're up against but
they're okay to be in there to drain the
coffers to make sure we are ill-equipped
to fight the battle from the Democrats
whether you know the Soros funded
billions that are going to go in to
harvest ballots in the inner cities
where there's going to be people you
know giving ballots that have no idea
who's even on the ballot uh so here he
is whining it crying that that the
Republicans are the ones who are who are
trying to get Donald Trump yeah no [__]
you're like you're in a primary you
[__] idiot that's how it works when
you don't hold the office you're in a
primary you're going to go up against
some Republicans now this goes into the
deeper narrative that I think they're
trying to spend okay I've been watching
this this morning I've I've done quite a
bit of work this morning on trying to
figure out exactly what the Trump camps
plan is with this narrative and they're
absolutely putting it into play here and
they're using even Tucker Carlson
yesterday with his episode about I don't
know what the [__] he's talking about he
did a 13 minute episode this [__] is
garbage it's trash it is isn't it man
it's boring you know what he don't have
them high dollar Fox producers and that
studio he looks like [__] he's horrible
at it he's [__] horrible at it to be
quite honest if he ain't got a team of
people to make him look good he sucks
well and it sucks to suck sometimes so
but again if you listen to Donald Trump
Junior's narrative there Donald Trump
Jr's narrative is that hey we need to
stop the Republicans from working with
the Democrats to try to stop Trump right
okay you follow that so he's claiming
that the Rhino Republicans are now
Democrats right that's what they're
doing that's the narrative
um and there's a certain word they used
to it I just don't want to say it out
loud yet I don't want to say it out loud
because I'm not 100 sure if this is
their total strategy and once I'm on to
it
we're going to engage in a
counter-offensive with this strategy
um so last night
um there was a couple different things
that popped up on TV okay and a few
people pointed them out this is the
first one you know Charlie Kirk is you
know that guy is oh yeah this [__]
this [__] cuck this is
damn Charlie Kirk he was really upset
last night that um here let me let me
see if I can show it here this is PBS
NewsHour okay they were they were
holding a little bit of the uh Trump
Wine Fest and I'm not talking about the
wine you drink I'm talking about the
tears that fall from the face and the
context is here they put context
literally this is on the Chiron on PBS
NewsHour they said experts warn that
inflammatory rhetoric from elected
officials or people in power can promote
individual actors to commit acts of
violence
PBS is just pointing out the truth here
is that Donald Trump is calling and
using a form of stochastic terrorism
right like they know it it's what he's
doing he's trying to incite a certain
level of people into taking matters into
their own hands quote unquote right
Charlie Kirk was really pissed off about
this okay he's really mad he says
taxpayer funded PBS goes full provider
look look
Charlie Kirk clearly does not know who
funds PBS he clearly does not now if
anyone out there wondering because that
was my question here's what I said I I
asked Charlie of course he didn't answer
me of course he didn't because he's a
[__] [__] ass [__] but I said who
do you think funds PBS
who do you think funds it because he's
calling to have it defunded does he know
does he know that only 15 percent of
PBS's budget
is funded by federal dollars to see no I
don't think he knows that I don't think
you know that either that or he's trying
to lie to his he's trying to lie to his
audience what do you think do you I
think PBS didn't go full profit I think
CP PBS went full Prada because that's
who funds
PBS is you got a bunch of of very
wealthy people that think you know we
really need to have our pelvis
and you know Marjorie was telling us
that PBS is hunting for funding so we
really should have let's have a little
Soiree up at the Hamptons
are you saying that PBS is boring as
[__] they're they're funded by Blue
Blood Blue Bloods like crazy which I
don't mind because I happen to like PBS
yes sure do you really I mean there are
there is some programming that I really
like on PBS but the news and how they
delivered the news oh my God it's a
snooze Fest it's a snooze Fest now they
do a pretty good job they do a pretty
good job of staying um quite
um non-bias and what I mean by that is
they don't play like MSNBC or or or or
or CNN where they're playing into the
advertiser's hands where they have to
get ratings right
um so so they so they do this whole well
we don't want to appear to be liberal we
want to appear to be non-biased and PBS
does a good job of like well we're just
we're not going to be
non-biased to the truth like it's the
truth what do you want from us it's not
liberal it's just a [__] truth I mean
if if liberalism is propped up by the
truth that's not our [__] problem
right like just because fascism is
smashed by truth that doesn't make it
still not the truth
you know I like their their their
international coverage quite a bit they
tend to be pretty spot on they don't
play into you know a bunch of BS and
yeah I I I I do I just I like their
international coverage their domestic
coverage is dry as [__] I mean I mean
you could it's like trying to eat toast
with no butter on it man
you know I mean Brad's good but damn I
mean put a little butter put a little
jam on it you know what I mean do a nice
impression every once in a while and you
would no I'm just
uh you would fit in right in at the
Hamptons if you shave that beer get rid
of that hat wear a suit and talk like
that you know that you fit right in
there at the Hamptons here's here's the
Chiron on Fox in these though everyone
lost their [__] over this now I actually
believe that this is [__] hilarious
and a lot of people are like oh this is
going to incite by him it's like what
violence that hasn't been incited yet
are you kidding me come on this this is
this is every [__] tweet from every
Twitter account that has a [__]
stupid blue check uh Elon blue check
behind it that is a Russian sycophant
right now right like this is all it is
but this is Fox News now I love the
freeze frame here of of Joe Biden and
Donald Trump uh having to you know
really get his lips around the water
bottle to take a sip did you know why he
does that a lot of people think it's
because he's got Dementia or some [__]
but do you know why he do you know why
he drinks water out of a water bottle
like that
to hit me with it so so the reason why
is because sometimes when you drink
water out of a water bottle especially a
full one the water can Splash back on
your face right like like when you take
a a quick drink a quick sip It'll like
Splash back on your face okay makeup
that's right that's right because if it
gets the water on his face his makeup
will run
you know it it'll have the Rudy Giuliani
you know problem yeah I hadn't thought
about it but you're spot on there I mean
no I know I well I I I'm always come on
I'm always right I mean
that's why he wouldn't go visit the
veterans uh you remember his last year
and he didn't go to uh um Arlington
because it was raining that day
everybody said it was about his hair but
your spot on it was the damn makeup I'm
sure
um someone's saying that Garland did
make some statements about Jack we're
gonna try to find those statements here
but I want to go to this first and then
we'll go to the Garland statements
um they're saying he's live but I'm
seeing the Justice Department's feed is
is gone
um now it's not it's not live so I don't
know exactly what happened there
um yeah it's it's overnight but we'll
we'll get those clips so grab those
clips um here is here's the Chiron
though
um because I was pointing out the water
bottle but here's the Chiron down at the
bottom this is the thing everyone was
really upset about it says wannabe
dictator speaks at the White House after
having his political rival arrested
which
none of that's [__] true like
obviously
obviously Joe Biden couldn't have his
political rival arrested I mean this is
what now this is pure projection right
here comes the projection because they
wanted Donald Trump to be the dictator
they wanted to overthrow the government
they wanted to overthrow our boat vote
they wanted to inject fraudulent
electors to make him King and to [__] on
the Constitution right that's what they
wanted we know that from the January 6
Select Committee in their investigation
already and we'll find out one more yeah
go ahead that's why I wish either the
Biden campaign or someone else in the
primary would sue Fox News to force
their coverage to be declared political
contributions because we knew Tony
you know this investigation started
before he was ever in the race we knew
he jumped in the race early just to make
this claim
and here Fox News is
blasting it out there to Grandpa you
know you're crazy yeah it's Uncle is is
sitting there watching it and you know
he's eating every damn word of it up
even though
you know he knows that the investigation
started before Trump was ever a
candidate
you know
and Joe Biden didn't tell Jack Smith who
to indict he didn't that's the whole
point of having Jack Smith is you get
Merrick Garland and the administration
out of the decisions
well not only that that you use a grand
jury in Miami a grand jury in Miami and
South Florida as as as the as the person
or as the group to indict Donald Trump I
mean yes the special prosecutor presents
a case to the grand jury and the grand
jury and and you know they say oh you
can indict a ham sandwich but this is
one of the most crooked [__] ham
sandwiches that we've seen in the system
uh to date especially in the political
realm
um yeah when you're charged with the
Espionage Act that doesn't speak well
I'm trying to find this but he wasn't he
wasn't even a candidate
when the investigation he wasn't even
when the crime he wasn't even a
candidate the January 6th investigation
sure he was trying to overthrow our
government that part they can say well
you're attacking your political Ally
well my our your political opposition
well I'm sorry but my political
opposition tried to engage in a [__]
coup okay
we have to look at that all right we
just kind of have to take a peek at that
right well but going back to the
politics of it because that's another
argument that the right makes and they
continue to make is all this is all
political it's all political I'm like
yeah so what so what so what if it's of
course there's political motivations the
reason like you said the reason why
Donald Trump jumped in the race act in
the investigation when he did is because
he wanted to make the political argument
that it's politically motivated and to
assume that Jack Smith the Department of
Justice the courthouse Miami security
the Secret Service anyone the Department
of Justice isn't [__] making
political calculations here because
Donald Trump is the one running for
president right like you chose to run
for president at this moment in time
this this was your choice no one forced
you to do it no one's forcing you to be
president or run for president it's your
choice
yeah of course it's political because
he's making it political so yeah sure I
mean if you want to have that argument
which is what JD Vance is doing right
now is political right political I mean
he is and he's clogging up all of
Congress
because he doesn't like he wants to slow
these investigations down so he wants to
punish the doj so instead of everything
that gets stipulated the time
stipulations all of that that normally
happens with any kind of nominee he's
making them go through every single
procedural bit of a minutia
which takes away time from everything
else that the Senate is supposed to be
looking at
you know he's intentionally punishing
you me the entire freaking country
because he's mad about an investigation
over a guy that's guilty as [__] well
here's here's that JD Vance clip that he
put out on social media let's take a
listen so I've announced today that I
will be holding all Department of
Justice nominees that Merit Garland will
use if confirmed not to enforce the law
and partially which is his duty but
clearly to harass his political
opponents I think that we have to grind
this department to a halt until Merrick
Garland promises to do his job and stop
going after his political opponents
Donald Trump is just one and then in the
most recent example of the fact that
Merrick Garland uses his department for
political purposes we have Catholic
fathers okay so this is just a portion
of his nonsense and again yeah it's
political the Republicans are making it
political they continue to make it
political I mean Jesus Christ they were
yelling and screaming yelling and
screaming around 17 recordings that
don't even exist don't even exist and
they want to impeach the president and
remove him and get the Democrats to make
sure they don't back him on the ticket
because they're scared Joe Biden is
going to beat Donald Trump because they
know Joe Biden is going to beat Donald
Trump that's why that's why they're
[__] terrified why do you think the
Democrats are like yeah sure let Donald
Trump be your nominee we know we're
going to beat him we know we're going to
[__] beat him that's why we're
encouraging them to to back Donald Trump
but of course it's all political
everything is [__] political to not
believe that it's stupid that's why I
say politicize everything
well listen to what the man said I'm
gonna grind the doj to a halt if you
don't stop investigating Donald Trump
right what the hell is that I mean is
that not political right I mean are you
telling me that Donald Trump can commit
any crime he wants because he was once
president
[__] like that kid on Tick Tock a
[__] a [__]
oh God damn
um did you know did you did you know
that um
today is someone's birthday
oh my God that's great it's his birthday
I tell you what man there's there's good
birthday presents and there's good
and there's good birthday presents but I
mean on Donald Trump's birthday for us
to be delivered that he's indicted and
arraigned now how many how many how many
felonies is he now charged with is this
70 how many 71 or 72 or something oh is
it something like that that's a lot of
four in the first one and then 34 in the
first one and then 37 in the second one
I think yeah so yeah that's what 71 yeah
yeah 71. so happy [__] birthday
happy happy
today is Donald Trump's birthday yeah
it's his birthday and it's also flag day
too
um which I actually believe that
um having the historical uh now
um record of Donald Trump that we should
probably move Flag Day I'm just saying
or move his birthday can we officially
do that can we like pass legislation and
move his birthday I don't know I'm just
I'm just saying I don't know it's a
government it's a government it's part
of a government ranker didn't it maybe
not I don't know maybe maybe it's maybe
it's written down in his family mind
comp you remember you know that's how
they used to record birthdays of their
of people's children's they have a
family Bible and they would they would
write down in the Bible the date that
the that the child was born in the
family bible but maybe at the Trump
house they wrote down his birthday in
the family mein conf I don't know it
could be dude just you know I've got
books on my there was a thing that
actually went around on Twitter about
that show us your your two read
collection and I've got a stack of books
on my nightstand that's you know about
yay tall I mean yeah and people were
showing the pictures and stuff this guy
really can't that's a true story he
really kept Mein Kampf on his bedside
table
as his two reads
books
I mean you know this goes into the
strategy that I've been observing
um here and I I'm gonna reach out to
Benjamin
um we've had him on a show he's a
professor and he he studies the second
world war but more importantly he
studies 1930s Germany not 20s 30s and
40s but the 30s mainly of the rise of uh
Nazis and Hitler and I want I want to
because I get a sense I get a sense from
this strategy that this strategy is the
same strategy that was deployed in 1930s
Germany
um and I may be wrong again it just may
be coincidence but I believe I believe
that this is the strategy that they're
that they're trying to put on us uh we
actually have I I do have uh excuse me I
do have uh breaking news here again a a
live picture here of um of uh Jack Smith
um we got video here I want to show it
here here is Jack Smith and this is him
have towards Donald Trump here this is
what it looked like in the courtroom
remember we talked about yesterday
rather Jack Smith would be in the
courtroom or not
um we weren't we weren't really sure but
we got news yesterday that yes Jack
Smith was in the courtroom and he was
staring down Donald Trump I guess but
Donald Trump did not gaze in his
Direction I wonder if that means that
Donald Trump is a coward and is scared
of Jack Smith do you think
yeah I mean you tend to I mean normally
Donald Trump tends to try to you know
push people and [__] like that try to
you know he's not a small guy don't get
me wrong he's a big guy
um but he tends to try to bully people
there's nothing for him to not even look
because there I mean there were several
accounts of this it wasn't didn't just
come from one person the Jack Smith the
entire hearing Drew I mean just lasers
right through Donald Trump the entire
time even as he walked out Jack Smith
never broke
you can't say I can't contact because
Donald Trump wouldn't look back at him
no and Donald Trump never once never
once turned his direction would not look
at him nothing he just sat there like
this but he did not Well here here's the
uh here's the court sketch room or the
excuse me the sketch of the courtroom uh
there from Jane Rosenberg and this is
apparently what Donald Trump looked like
grimacing and he's mad bro I mean he's
mad right like this is this is not a
person that's having fun if I if I if I
got this sketch and said hey the guy in
the red tie does it look like he's
having fun in this picture
um but you know what you know what this
picture doesn't show but makes obvious
is that Jack Smith has got laser eyes in
the back of this guy's this guy's bald
little skull that's covered by a few
hairs don't you think I think it does
yeah maybe I'm wrong I don't know I love
art and this is a great piece of art
this is a piece of art that someone
could frame and stick up on their wall
you know
I mean you know what else I loved was
that [__] fake
um motorcade
oh yeah okay yeah he I mean he rented a
bunch of uh of SUVs to try to those were
not Secret Service SUVs they weren't no
she rented those yes yeah no [__] he
rented those from a security company to
try to make a presidential looking
motorcade and you see the way they did
you see afterwards like when the guy
jumped in front of one of them with a he
was wearing a jail suit
and then he got arrested I think it was
a restaurant now or some [__] but that
that was uh
the drivers of those SUVs didn't know
what the hell to do Secret Service would
have known exactly what to do in that
situation you know I mean I think your
service ran over to the guy and they
kind of got him out of the way
um and then local the local authorities
came and and eventually arrested the guy
I think is is yeah local PD took him
into custody and put them in because a
bunch of the the the freakazoids that
were there started to try to surround
the guy in the local local police took
him out of there but the whole point of
it is that that was all states to try to
make Donald Trump look like he's still
some important presidential he's not
he's an old man that lives on the beach
in Florida that's it right he's an
ex-president who is now
um facing 71 felony counts in two
different states
uh here's the clip of Merrick Garland uh
giving some statements uh on Jack Smith
let's listen
can you give the American public a very
clear sense of what exactly your role
was in the indictment process just so
people can understand what that role is
and then secondarily uh given the
historic and extraordinary nature of the
case explain to people if you would why
this was the best and most appropriate
step that was taken and why there were
no other alternatives
um I'm trying to remember the first
first question
yes so my role has been completely
consistent with the regulations that set
forth responsibilities to the attorney
general under the special uh Council
regulations and I followed uh those
regulations uh with respect to the
second question this again is asking for
particulars and I'm not going to be able
to comment
um
um all the comments on this will have to
come in filings in court and there you
go there you have it and that's what
Garland it's what an attorney general
should say right like that's what they
should say no matter the case no matter
who's being charged no matter what the
circumstance he should follow the rules
and regulations and he should keep his
mouth shut and the court the court
should be the one who lets this
discovery out it should be the trial
that does this now I believe that we're
not going to see a trial for a long time
here because that is one thing that
Eileen Cannon is going to afford Donald
Trump is the ability to delay delay
delay at every single pass at every
single measure and I believe they're
going to get this delayed into primary
elections When Donald Trump starts to
collect up delegates Donald Trump will
have a very good argument in court folks
you don't like to hear this and I don't
even like to say it but this is the
truth and I'm not going to [__] you
here
When Donald Trump starts collecting up
delegates we should not stand in the way
of Voters we shouldn't do that we
shouldn't we sh the Department of
Justice and the court system should
adjourn they should take a break and let
the people speak that is our job we
should be afforded the right to do our
job and when he starts collecting up
delegates and it looks like he's going
to be the nominee Eileen Cannon should
rule that she should punt this [__]
trial past the election that is what
should happen and I'm not just saying it
because it's Donald Trump I'm saying it
in general in general this is how our
country should operate you may not like
it it may not sound all the what thing
you want to hear but what you want to
hear is not always the truth all right
excuse me what you what you want to hear
is the true well not what you the truth
is not always something you want to hear
excuse me but it is the truth it is the
truth that the Department of Justice
should not thumb their nose into an
election like they did in 2016. they
should not not an interfere James Comey
should have never ever gave public
statements on any investigation in the
Hillary Clinton he never should have
written a letter to members of Congress
that would have leaked those [__]
investigations into Hillary Clinton
which swayed the vote the people should
have the right to vote
and Donald Trump did this of his own
accord after he was President he
announced his presidential run after
this investigation started that's his
problem but when it comes down to him
winning delegates which he will he's
going to win them
at that point in time that the justice
system should stand out of the way they
should not engage
in in that in that process it should be
us that engages and that's why I want to
tell you the truth I want to give it to
you even though you don't want to hear
it is that Donald Trump is not going to
see a [__] trial until after this
election which makes you the audience
which makes you the people the voters
his jury his next jury that he will face
um and I think Merrick Garland gave
again Not only was it a canned statement
there Texas Paul but I believe he's
practiced it a few times in the last few
days when he was asked this question
what how he would respond what do you
think
oh yeah they they do that a lot of
people don't realize that but yeah these
these that's part of he's got assistance
political assistance that that is part
of their job is to make sure he's ready
for those kinds of questions and yeah
he's practiced that one before I
guarantee you I can give your one or sit
right on that
um so there's some committee hearings
today and have you and I'm just noticing
this clip I haven't watched it yet but I
I want to pull it up and I know it has
nothing to do with what we're we're
talking about besides how stupid manga
is and how we can mock them but do you
remember do you remember representative
Crockett
um a couple weeks ago she had this great
clip in this hearing where she just
absolutely slam dunks uh and I forget
which Maga it was I love the paper at
the end yep yep it was a fantastic clip
um here She is again here She is again
um going after Lauren Boward I think is
is what's happening here I don't know
let's listen I I'm I'm always doing
doing this
this committee runs my pressure up uh
and and and I I do come prepared to
committee and then there's always
somebody from this side that does
something ridiculous that that throws me
all the way off
so uh oh Jesus okay so this is where we
gonna start Miss caskin
um first of all let me apologize because
that was uncalled for so let me do what
she would never do uh which is to be an
adult in this room or in this chamber so
let me start there I'm also going to
start with some nonsense that she was
trying to spew and unlike Miss bobert I
am legally trained and I've passed a few
bar exams and I also legislated before I
got here so I do want to start with
um correcting the record a little bit
and if you want to add to that please do
uh there was conversation about ATF
because my colleagues love to talk about
their guns baby and I'm from Texas so
let me be clear I also own firearms let
me Democrats on guns too let me make it
clear I I own guns and I'm licensed to
carry that is a regulation regulations
aren't necessarily bad it didn't stop me
from being able to get a gun
um so we were talking about or y'all
were talking about the ATF which I
wasn't going there I didn't plan to go
there uh but you know what I I honestly
wish the ATF would run amok because we
know that seemingly the people that run
this chamber don't have the courage to
come up with one of the things we've
heard is common sense regulations when
it comes to guns and to be clear our
constitution the Second Amendment
anticipates people having Common Sense
unfortunately we have not done that and
unfortunately it has cost us lives so
when you were testifying a little bit
earlier you talked about unintended
consequences and the fact that we are
supposed to be able to anticipate that
as lawmakers when we are writing laws
unfortunately not only have we ignored
the unintended consequences but we've
got foreseeable consequences that are
continually ignored and that is why we
are talking about regulation at least on
this side of the
there she is and she man she doesn't let
up she just lays into him right she does
not the the statement where she's like
Democrats own guns dummies we own guns
and Democrats want to own guns I I I
can't tell you how I'm refreshing now
Goldman is sitting there I don't know if
you notice Goldman in the background
he's kind of uncomfortable this guy's
really he's like should I be on camera
should I not be on he's like he knows
he's in the camera shot right I know
he's like I don't know what I should
he's like
oh man because Goldman is good at this
too right Goldman is is fantastic he's
such a warrior at this too but Goldman
has such a different tone than Crockett
and I actually think I appreciate both
tones to be quite honest and I believe
that both tones are needed in the
Congress and needed in these committees
and I think I think she's supposed to be
a great leader in the House of
Representatives I really do Crockett
she's super smart not only she's super
smart she speaks like like her
constituents want her to speak you know
a lot of people say that [__] about
Donald Trump they say oh he just speaks
his mind right he just says what he
wants and there's something to that
argument right there's something to the
argument about listening to someone who
who speaks like you he doesn't talk over
top of you who doesn't trying to talk
down at you
um who doesn't try to talk at you but
talks with you and Crockett really does
I get the feeling that Crockett when
you're when you're having a conversation
with your she's having a conversation
with you right like if you were in a
room with her and you you were having
conversation should be having
conversation with you not over top of
you or at you right
um and um she's supposed to be a leader
not only that
um because she's a woman and a black
woman I think it is the face of what the
leadership in this country should look
like I believe that if you want to call
it own the fash let's own the fashion
let's make Crockett a leader in the
Democratic party in the house because I
think she truly is
um Gonna Shine there as she continues to
be represented now here is here here is
the clip here's the clip I guess this is
um
maybe this is
I love how she's scared the [__] out of
Dan Goldman right there yeah
because I just keep getting bigger and
bigger where are you where
where's plane landing man
he's not sure you know and let me tell
you something if you make someone uh as
intelligent and as good at that um like
Goldman nervous you know that Crockett's
on to something you know that she's onto
something there when you make Goldman
nerves here's uh Lauren bobert
apparently in the same hearing let's see
what the dummy has to say here Emily
home it may not be a 2.5 million dollar
home like yours but that sounds like a
lot of red tape to me excuse me I really
take that as a personal do you disagree
my home do you disagree that this was an
overall I disagreements
[Music]
Mr chairman
um could we just ask all of our good
members to respect whoa whoa Jamie Rask
and easy on the good members thing easy
on the just say members now this is if
you're not aware this is Jamie Raskin
um in response to Lauren bobert here but
this is Jamie you're asking in response
and Jamie you're asking just called
Lauren bobert a good member I take
offense to that Jamie but let's see what
how Jamie um uh does a point of order
here and tries to smash what Lauren
bobert just tried to say good members to
respect uh the civility in decorum and
the uh Integrity of the witnesses who've
come forward at their own expense to
testify uh before us today and in an
insult is not a substitute for an
argument go back to the chair would
advise the members to adhere to the
house standard of the Quorum and proceed
in order
um Miss Crockett of Texas is recognized
for five minutes and you see nobody
laughed at him when he said that nobody
acted him like they did 40 March right
right well here's well that's because he
actually practices decorum but if you
see in the shot here
um let me mute this because I want to
back it up so look look at that look at
the look at uh the person walking off
the screen here that is Lauren bobert so
she got up as Jamie you're asking was
speaking she was gonna sit and listen
but she's like nope I'm out of here and
then when she was reprimanded by the
chair which she knew she was going to be
she quickly hurried out of the room so
she didn't hear that uh the the chairman
reprimanding her for her conduct
um that way she can claim because she's
going to claim oh I didn't I didn't know
that I I didn't hear that I I got up and
laughed I is what she's going to claim
um because this is why she misses
critical votes you know I mean well
she's a [__] idiot um what was the
vote that she missed and then she lied
about why she missed it was it the um
was it the gas stoves thing or was it
which one was it which one was it she
missed a vote I don't even remember like
she was running uh to go vote and oh it
was the debt ceiling that's what it was
it was the debt ceiling deal she was
running to go vote and they had closed
the vote and when she was running in
someone said no they already closed it
she's like they closed it like yeah they
closed it they caught her on the steps
on camera and then later on Lauren
bobert tried to say why didn't vote
intentionally which is all [__] she
tried to she was just late for the boat
is all she was because she doesn't do
her job and why they keep hiring me back
there in California to do that she was
there to talk all the smacks she was
there to stand in front of the cameras
and pretend like she's doing [__] but
when it actually came down to actually
doing [__]
you know where was she where the hell
was she you know again again I don't
believe I don't believe that Lauren
bobert wants to do anything to be quite
honest uh let's see uh we've got a lot
of stuff coming in here
[Music]
um
I'm trying to see but you know why are
you looking that up I just you know the
reason that you got the reaction that
you did from the chair the audience
everybody was because Jamie Raskin
adheres to house policies you're
supposed to refer to other congressmen
as your friend
you're supposed to my friend from across
the aisle that's all in place to promote
decorum so that these people who do not
agree on a damn thing can work together
when they have to these rules are in
place for for a reason
Jamie Raskin follows them Lauren bobert
does not she is there to be a freaking
spectacle to draw attention to herself
because she's got her free government
job you know where she's getting paid
174 000 a year which is more than she's
ever made in her lifetime
and and
for God's sakes Tony if she if she makes
it through this next election cycle we
have to pay that more on a pension for
life
oh how sad is that
how sad is that if we would have to pay
her a pension I mean if you vote against
Lauren bobert for any reason vote
against her for that
just so she doesn't get a damn pension
right well that is a good enough reason
not to
um this is what I want to I'm going to
go to this morning uh here is Steve
scalise now
it's kind of Uncle is this like the
[__] the congressman's game or
something it's at the Nationals Park but
he's doing an interview on Fox News
Steve scalise
um who is the congressman from Louisiana
that's why he has the LSU uniform on
here I'm assuming
um but this is his response to Donald
Trump being charged with 37 felonies a
lot of them under the Espionage Act this
is he's a leader in the house
I mean if you want to call him a leader
let's listen if his name was Donald
Smith would this be happening and I
think most people recognize no there's a
different level of treatment because a
lot of people have just said they want
to just Target Donald Trump you know Joe
Biden we've got did you did you notice
that let me back that up a second watch
watch this watch this a lot of people
have just said they want to just Target
Donald Trump you know Joe Biden
what I did did you follow that he's like
yeah people want a job follow yeah down
jump Joe Biden they just throw Joe Biden
in the mix there right he didn't give
context he didn't say why it's it's all
[__] victimies and propaganda man
let's keep listening we've got so much
coming out on the the Biden family
millions of dollars for facial
corporations
exposing nothing those agencies you look
at Hillary Clinton's server other people
that have handled classified documents
it's just all the buzzwords Texas Paul
it's all the victimies buzzwords
barishma hunter Baden Hillary's emails
it's really [__] it's scuzzy isn't it
and it pisses me off Tony it really
makes me angry because you know Donald
Trump you know you know damn well he was
handled like no one else on the freaking
planet would have been handled yesterday
exactly nobody else everybody else would
have they would they would have given up
that passport they had been told they
couldn't leave the county much less
travel all over the world you know he
would have been fingerprinted mug shots
would have been out uh he would have
been in pre-trial detention until he
made bail he would have had a bail if
this had been just your
Donald Smith
Donald Smith yeah right he'd have been
treated a hell of a lot worse Not only
would yeah and not only would we be
prosecuting him we would have prosecuted
him a long time ago they wouldn't have
been so careful about this investigation
as soon as they had something boom he'd
have been he would have been tried
and God I mean we just had a lieutenant
colonel
just got sent to prison for three years
for far less than this right had it been
Donald Smith
damn right right and that's that's the
fallacy in their argument of well if
they can do this to Trump they can do it
to you yes if they can do it to you they
damn well better be sure to be able to
do it to Donald Trump uh another example
of this two-tier justice system that I
pointed out earlier
um was David Petraeus right he got to
take advantage of the two-tier justice
system
um David Petraeus again I'll remind
people he was a general
um he was he was actually in charge of
operations overseas during war times and
he was in charge he was the big guy the
big guy the big man whatever they want
to call but the point is this is that
David Petraeus when he was having his
book written for him uh by an author he
was having an affair with that woman who
was writing the book and David Petraeus
not only showed her information National
Security information that he wasn't
supposed to show her he left it in her
possession and he was charged with
felonies now David Petraeus took
advantage of the two-tier justice system
in the normal way that rich white men
who have lots of power take advantage of
the two-tier justice system what he did
was is he got high powerful attorneys
paid them a shitload of money and they
went and they used the two-tier justice
system to get the charge knocked down
from a felony which was clear that David
Petraeus committed a felony in this
because he admitted to it by pleading to
a misdemeanor a still a crime still a
criminal misdemeanor but he did plead
down to a misdemeanor so he didn't have
to serve any jail time but again that's
an example of the two-tier justice
system that manga is talking about that
was that gave that afforded privilege to
David Petraeus the same thing they're
mad about is that Donald Trump is not
being afforded those special privileges
under the two-tier justice system now
he's afforded a lot of them like you
pointed out Texas Paul but not all of
them not like pure immunity or but
Donald Trump is did this to himself if
he have just
if he would have just
when asked for those documents gave them
back or to the point of obstruction
would have given them back because I
believe that that there's some point
where the department Justice says you
know what we can't [__] around with this
guy no more we want to [__] around with
him we want to give him leeway we got to
treat him special but we can anymore
he's now obstructing there's nothing we
can do about it because he's actively
obstructing and his attorneys were
saying he's obstructing they they
[__] went and told the special
counsel he was obstructing so they
couldn't afford him the two-tier justice
system that Maga wants to afford him
they they J he he he made it impossible
but portrayal didn't make it impossible
do you remember the David Petraeus trial
there wasn't a David Patrice there
wasn't a David Petraeus trial because
David Petraeus did exactly what Donald
Smith would have done he said guilty to
his crimes he negotiated with the
prosecutors he owned what he did
he cooperated everything that Donald
Trump is not doing right
or Donald Smith whichever one you want
to say I mean if if Donald Smith wasn't
was acting like Donald Trump like you
said Donald Smith would be in a [__]
helding cell right now in an orange
jumpsuit uh eating eating pudding with
three fingers possibly I'm just saying
and Dave David Petraeus was the the head
of the CIA he was what did David
Petraeus do after he got caught
he went away
right which is what Donald Trump would
have to do which is why we're going to
have to have a trial for Donald Trump
because it's not the pleading out part
that Donald Trump has a problem with
it's that after pleading out part of the
deal will be go away and Donald Trump
can't make money in business he loses
money in business are you saying are you
saying he's a shitty businessman is that
what you're saying absolutely he was
about to go bankrupt with all of his
golf his real estate Empire was
crumbling like Trump's stakes and Trump
water and Trump University and the
casinos and everything else he was
bankrupting them
and then he became president and then
all of a sudden money started showing up
after he became president
he cannot go away this is his most
successful grift he has ever had this is
the only way he's ever really made money
is running for president and taking
money from your papa
you know I mean that's the part of the
deal he can't take the go away part
well that and he's not gonna go away uh
anytime soon
um let me show you a couple clips from
last night as we ramp up here here's a
clip last night where he throws out
Hillary's emails just like Steve scalise
did and tried to try to is trying to
make this argument most and famously of
all Hillary Clinton set up
an illegal private server in her
basement you never heard this story
with the most infamous again back to the
Hillary Clinton thing and folks when
when these idiots say this [__] when
they do this what about ISM with Hillary
Clinton again just tell them that you
have heard people saying that Barack
Obama has said publicly that he used his
mind to declassify all those emails when
he was president just say that I know
it's not true I know it sounds crazy but
what it'll do is it will get them to
tell you that your argument is not only
a lie but that is not how it works
that's what they'll tell you and then
you can start to maybe uh start to
perpetuate this this reality snowball
for them uh it probably won't work
because these people are way too in debt
uh uh in delusion so
um here's another here's another
um weird moment in the speech last night
and there's a lot of weird moments but
here's another one this is one where he
takes a drink by the way Texas Paul
let's listen to this oh you know Joe
didn't have your mind have a drink
okay did you see that there
Joe didn't mind and then he takes drink
watch as he drinks
you know Joe didn't have your mind have
a drink
so what he does okay and this this is
why I'm just going off of what I know
here what he does is he sticks his
entire lip around the opening of the
bottle because again these are brand new
water bottles they have not been they
have not been opened
and when you got a full water bottle
like that sometimes when you tip it back
the air will suck down inside and spit
the water back on your face so what he
does is he puts his lips around the
entirety of the opening to make sure
that that water cannot Splash Back on
his face and the reason why is because
he doesn't want his makeup to run he
doesn't want the Rudy Giuliani problem
as it were but let's listen to the rest
of the clip here
it's a little bit cooler than it was
it's pretty hot out here
thank you happy birthday happy birthday
great birthday
nice birthday isn't it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
Texas ball they can't even sing in
unison this is how [__] ridiculous
they are they can't even sing in unison
not only they lost the plot line here
with the grandpa poopy pants but they
can't even Sing Happy Birthday
is this re Is that real that they can't
know how to sing Happy Birthday come on
man
I can't tell you man I I have really
given up on on Republican voters they're
just I just
I I I I really am I'm dumbstruck I look
at these people and I'm like
how
how are you this stupid how how can you
if you hear and see the same things I do
how are you this stupid
you know it is astonishing like the
thing that is astounding
is that after reading this indictment
which some of these people in like the
Twitter spaces that is and said said
that they read the indictment and when
they read this indictment they see the
total opposite of what is in the
indictment like how and they're starting
to make up stories I'll tell you one um
story that they're trying to make up
here's one story that's trying to make
up about the indictment that is clearly
not true if you just read the indictment
and and put the story together
indictment what they're saying at
betmenster when he's showing the person
the documents right and he's saying I
can't declassify these because I'm not
president you remember that Port part of
the transcript
they're saying that now that he wasn't
actually showing them a documents he was
showing them a news article article
about the documents that's not true that
it's not true the material evidence in
the indictment says that he was showing
maps and he was showing plans to someone
at Bedminster
it's it's [__] astounding that they
can read this the material evidence
because folks it doesn't matter what you
believe
about Donald Trump and this evidence
whether it's true or not the special
counsel in the doj cannot put this
evidence in an indictment like that
without having shown the grand jury some
of this evidence to get them to vote on
this indictment they had to see the
material evidence and the grand jury
voted on the material Evans it's it's
just astounding here's another clip from
last night
again more lunacy but let's let's listen
to it this is the delusion that they're
going with they lawlessly pierced
my attorney client privilege with
lawyers what they did to lawyers what
they have done to our lawyers our
lawyers all of our lawyers they've done
things that were absolutely horrible and
unthinkable
the leaking has been unbelievable and
highly illegal they leak
we've learned more about
from The Washington Post New York Times
about the doj's boxes hoax it's a boxes
hoax then from prosecutors themselves we
okay so there's a lot to break down in
this clip number one this sounds like
Jim Jones have you ever heard the tapes
of Jim Jones talking at Jonestown holy
[__] when I listened to some of these
clips this morning my God damn this
sounds like Jim [__] Jones it's
[__] weird like it's weird if you go
back and listen to some of those tapes
of Jim Jones talking in the microphone
or into the megaphone at Jonestown he
had like a little radio station and they
had they had micro are they had speakers
all over the Jonestown that he could
speak to these people this is what it
sounded like it was [__] wild [__]
the government's after him which means
the government's after you and he's the
government's after us he would say this
[__] it's [__] wild [__] but here's
the thing
at the very end he's talking about leaks
and I I think me and you talked about
this the other day and I've been saying
this that Jack Smith and the prosecutors
didn't leak [__] every single leak that
has come out that we know about this
from The New York Times The Washington
Post or any other publication is because
of trump it's because of trump and when
he says the illegal leaks if they're
illegal men you're guilty so but again
it's all projection right Paul I mean
come on who's going to believe that Jack
Smith leaked this thing and who believes
that Donald Trump leaked this thing
nobody nobody believes that not not in
the slightest I mean this guy is just
such a sleaze bag I mean he really is
and it just pisses me off Tony that that
we're having to deal with this you know
Republicans are trying to do this Cry Me
a River oh you're Prosecuting this I'm
pissed at you for making us have to do
this
it's your fault that we're here you
heard the Access Hollywood tapes you saw
him mock the reporters you heard him on
the you know making talk well you didn't
hear the call but you saw the
transcripts from the call to Ukraine you
know damn well
he tried to Blackmail Vladimir zielinski
and the people of Ukraine over and over
again you have seen
all of this
and you're the reason he's still here
he shouldn't be here
he shouldn't be here and if you look at
the crowd that's around him like the
crowd yesterday all they care about is
this WWE spectacle [__] that has
nothing to do with our government
our country nothing it's all
entertainment to them
you know these people are listening to
him that that are up there at Bedminster
or wherever the hell he was at on the on
this clip these are not people that
actually care about your country
they don't they don't give a damn
they're there because they get this
feeling
you know they get to be like that like
that guy that they found out who
remember the girl that was on in the
track and field event and the the couple
was screaming at the girl get that boy
off the field insinuating that she was
transgender and they were so freaking
rude about it they actually moved the
kids away from them well we found out
who that guy is
looks exactly like a Trumper exactly
little man you know he obviously takes
testosterone because when you're you
know you're my age you're not ripped
unless you're taking testosterone you're
not you're just not if you're not
pumping down testosterone you do you are
not jacked at all he looks like he had
the chest implants you know what I mean
talking about gender affirming surgery
right right you know what I mean he
looks exactly gold chains he looks
exactly the fake ass tan exactly like
you'd expect yeah and that's what these
people get off of this is they get to be
their shittiest versions of themselves
and they think they're getting away with
it and they're not Tony because we're
not going to forget who you are
we're not going to forget you did this
[__] Trump will be dead soon you know I
I'm going to tell you Trump will be dead
soon that guy's never taken care of
himself
ever in his life
and then what then what people
you've been this [__] forever you
think we're gonna forget
uh We're Not Gonna forget your life is
screwed forever over this guy
it's true anyway that's my rant well
here's here's um here's here's the last
clip I'll show of uh Grandpa's little
Wine Fest uh yesterday after his
arraignment and here's here's a little
bit more and he says he's the only one
that can he's the only one that can fix
it
I will appoint a real special prosecutor
to go after the most corrupt president
of the history of the United States of
America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
name a special prosecutor
and all others involved with the
destruction of our elections our borders
and our country itself they're
destroying our country
and when I'm re-elected and we will get
reelected we have no choice we're not
going to have a country anymore I will
totally obliterate the Deep State we
will obliterate
did he not just just trash his whole own
defense his whole argument they're
picking on me because he just said right
there I'm gonna go after Biden I'm going
to appoint a special product right not
not to look at a crime not to look at
this happen that happened this specific
thing happened it's just I'm gonna go
after Biden period it's all projections
it's all projection it's always
projection always with these [__]
idiots
and we know who they are I know exactly
who they are
they want to take away my freedom
because I will never let them take away
your friend Jesus Christ
they want to silence me because I will
never let them silence you they want you
silence
yes
because you know they're not coming
after me they're coming after you and I
just happened no we're coming after you
I will never be moving
and there you have it and that again
this this speech is the one that I can
point to the most that really starts to
sound like the Jim Jones tapes from
Jonestown uh when he would speak to all
the people at Jonestown through the the
little uh uh PA system that he had there
uh if you go back and you watch
documentaries with Jim Jones wear those
tapes because they have recordings of
this because he would record himself too
um if you go back and you listen to
those you'd be like Jesus [__] Christ
he would even stand like in like their
Pavilion Texas ball Jim Jones is
standing a pavilion and he would kind of
hold like a little amplifier with a
microphone on it right and he would
stand and talk to him like this and and
it's wild [__] man it's wild [__] how
much this sounds like the verbiage the
tone the even even like the um the the
tick tock of it it feels like that Jim
Jones uh at Jonestown is [__] same
grip oh yeah they're not coming after me
they're coming after you right you know
they want to take your freedoms and I'm
gonna stop them because I'm so powerful
but you have to help me you have to you
know what you know what's crazy about
this argument they're like oh my God we
gotta go get the Deep State and the
leftist lunatic Marxist maniacs and then
they're like we couldn't stop them
because they stopped us of stopping them
like Jesus Christ when are you people
gonna [__] wake up and Rise they're
grifting you and they're lying to you
Jesus Christ
and they know who these people are right
yeah I but he doesn't know who the frick
Walt NADA is I guarantee you this
morning the same guy that got indicted
next to him he's somebody told him well
you know you can't talk to the case you
know just a reminder don't talk to Walt
about the case who's wrong who's wrong
he's your freaking valet he's the guy
that was just in the room with us
the towel boy yeah indicted
where did they indict the towel boy
I mean he has no freaking clue from one
minute to the next
you know he just walks around all day
where's my raccoon where's my Roy [__]
well you know this guy literally
believes that if
you rob a bank with a crew full of
lawyers
they can't indict you because they're
your lawyers you know I mean he's a
[__] he's just a [__] and the only
people stupider than Donald Trump are
the dumbasses that vote for him or his
children his children are steeper than
you know here's Eric Trump this was his
uh tweet
um when they were headed to Miami he
tweeted this I'm not shooting it says
watching the plane from the plane part
number two man let me tell you how
average working Americans really relate
to this Eric
what the [__] are you [__] kidding me
this is his tweet this is how how
[__] wild this is that average
working toothless Americans just white
Christian nationalists in this country
rule white people have bought into this
blue-collar billionaire [__] that Eric
Trump tweets from their [__] private
jet
wow on this [__] 60-inch TV screen on
their jet taking a picture
of their jet on national TV because they
get all the Press I can't tell you how
[__] I can't I just I can't even
explain it I can't they're that arrogant
they're that
arrogant these are the people that think
that they've got an invisible Sky wizard
that's their best friend that pays
attention to all their thoughts think
that they have a billionaire
that really gives a [__] A I'm important
to Trump I'm important to Trump he loves
me yeah okay Trump don't give a [__]
about you you ignorant arrogant jackass
you are not important to him at all if
you closed your wallet and said I'll
vote for you
get the [__] out of here
well let me give you an example this
before we go because we're running over
time here let me get an example of this
you remember when the Kansas City Chiefs
won the Super Bowl and Donald Trump is
President United States tweeted out
Kansas is a great state
the the problem about Donald Trump and
the Kansas City Chiefs the reason why he
didn't know that it it's not that he
doesn't know that there's a Kansas City
Kansas in the Kansas City Missouri right
it's that he has never been to Kansas
City
and he would never he would never ever
ever
open a hotel in Kansas City no [__]
way would that guy ever [__] build a
hotel in Kansas City because he thinks
it's scummy he thinks Kansas City is
scumming right that's his view of it
because oh only scum lives in that part
of the country that's why he had no idea
that the Kansas City Chiefs stadium
Arrowhead is in Independence Missouri
Independence Missouri which is not a
long ways away from Kansas City Kansas
but it's like as far as Kansas City the
metropolitan area is considered
Independence is like as far away as from
Kansas City Kansas as Kansas City gets I
don't even know that but Arrowhead and
is way the [__] away from Kansas City
Kansas as far as the metropolitan area
is concerned and he doesn't even know
that but but it just goes to show you
that he doesn't give a [__] about these
people he doesn't give a [__] about what
they care about because people in that
part of the country who are Chiefs fans
and Trump fans they were like what what
they were kind of like what because I I
mean it was real time I was like texting
people that I know that are Trump and
Kansas City Chiefs fans I'm like how do
you feel about this they're like well
it's kind of weird that he doesn't know
that the Chiefs play in Missouri I mean
I didn't they're like oh well it says
Kansas in the in the actual name I'm
like yeah but Kansas City
most people when you think of Kansas
City you don't think of Kansas
you think of Missouri
but he doesn't know yeah but you know
this is the same guy that lived in New
York for decades and couldn't figure out
why his driver kept driving him to New
Jersey every time he went to a freaking
Giants game I mean he has no freaking
clue about
any of this stuff he just thought it was
a shortcut to come across the bridge and
oh [__] oh [__] Texas fall you always
have a great way of pointing out his
stupidity I appreciate it I appreciate
you joining me for the second half as
the guest co-host today is Gabe Sanchez
had to take take off
um and I appreciate you uh throwing into
our show today how'd that go
ah it was great man it was great it went
good it really went good everything
smoothed out I was watching that clock
the last few minutes and I was making
sure I was not I was like okay it is
Wednesday not Sunday I don't have cart
Blanche to do whatever the hell I want
to do I've got a time limit here that's
I've warn people ahead of time you know
we've only got you know a couple times
I'm like okay we've got seven minutes
left we've got five minutes left Well
here here's what I'll tell you everybody
if you want to text check out Texas
Paul's show before our show on Wednesday
and on Sundays he does a show as well go
to realtexaspaul.com that's
realtexaspaul.com Fall Texas fall
everywhere on social media definitely
follow us YouTube channel and watch his
show before us on Wednesday and also
check his show out on Wednesday again
it's real Texas Paul not common link is
down below but you can just type it in
in your browser realtexaspaul.com and
follow him everywhere Texas Paul I
appreciate you uh also if you're on
YouTube right now subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast it's free follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels on download
every single episode every single
weekday Monday through Friday on Apple
Spotify and Google you can also watch it
on Facebook if you want to watch it
somewhere else you can go to at the Tony
Michaels watch it on Facebook speaking
of YouTube channels don't forget to go
to the upwire.com or just type in the up
wire on YouTube you can find the up
buyers Channel you can follow us there
get in the chat there it's a great chat
over on the UMP wires Channel if you
want to get in there Jim is our
moderator over there also follow us on
Twitter it's free go to twitch.tv not
our slash D Tony Michaels excuse me
that's twitch.tv Tony Michaels it's free
to follow us on Twitch there's also a
great Lively chat over on Twitch and I
appreciate all the people over there on
Twitch who have used their Amazon Prime
account to subscribe
to our twitch Channel
there's bound to be more news tomorrow
there always is with these moglodytes
it's going to continue it won't stop
anytime soon same time same place
tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon